[Applause]  uh  i'll go to english  so i'm incredible i'm incredibly excited  to  hand over the first production cars  from our incredible team here at giga  berlin brandenburg  this is a great day  for the factory and  you know it's  i just like to thank everyone who helped  thank you thank you very much uh it  really made a very big difference  um and to the community  and uh  i mean tesla will will make sure  that this is a uh a gem  uh you know a gemstone for  the area for germany for europe and for  the world  uh this is yeah it's gonna be  yeah every every vehicle that we make  will be another  uh step in the direction of a  sustainable energy future  automobile fabric indeed  chief  [Applause]  wow